aller retour sur les grands
enseignements de cette crise sanitaire
sans précédent avec le gouverneur de la
banque de france françois villeroy de
galhau bonjour bonjour
allez-vous mercier trolard sur public
sénat déjà première question peut-être
un peu plus pour le coup personnel est
ce que cette crise a changé ou pas
d'ailleurs un votre rapport à l'économie
et ce qu'elle a amendé fait évoluer
certaines de vos croyances de nos
convictions économiques ou pas du tout
la réponse est sans doute quelque part
entre les deux
peut-être deux sentiments qui me
viennent le premier c'est je crois que
la crise nous amener temps à réagir
beaucoup plus vite je n'oublierai jamais
la première semaine du confinement vous
souvenez en mars 2020 en 48 heures ont
dû basculer tous les hommes et les
femmes de la banque de france en
télétravail et on a dû décider le 18
mars au soir le plus la plus grosse
intervention de l'histoire de l'euro au
téléphone depuis depuis chez nous nos
choix qu'on a agi vite et bien
d'ailleurs et puis peut-être un autre
enseignement c'est une confirmation
c'est que la crise a encore augmenté
l'importance d'être sur le terrain au
plus près de tous les acteurs
économiques dont les entrepreneurs nous
les écoutons énormément par des enquêtes
mensuelles par des rencontres que j'ai
voilà pour qu'ils nous disent comment
ils ont vécu les hauts et les bas de la
crise parce que le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que ça a été une période sans
précédent il a fallu évidemment
préserver le niveau de vie des français
éviter des faillites en cascade et donc
on assistait une intervention massive de
l'état pour sauver l'économie d'un
désastre et c'est ce qu'on appelle quoi
qu'il en coûte il est évidemment
nécessaire il ya pas vraiment de débat
là dessus après est ce qu'on en a trop
fait est-ce que l'arrosage a été trop
massif ou est-ce que c'est pas un sujet
je crois que globalement ça a été bien
fait c'est assez rare qu'à gouverneur la
banque de france dit ce qu'il fallait
des déficits beaucoup plus important et
qu'il fallait augmenter la dette
publique c'est ce qui se passait en
france et ce qui s'est passé la plupart
des pays européens c'est ce qui s'est
passé au niveau de l'europe dans son
ensemble puisque on a décidé une
intervention concertée à un programme
d'investissement de 750 milliards qui
n'avait pas de précédent après on peut
toujours discuter ce que au milliard
près ce que sur telle ou telle aide on
pouvait faire encore mieux enfin vous
c'est dans l'action il vaut mieux faire
bien que chercher à optimiser à tout
moment créant trop de règles de la
bureaucratie ge surtout des retards non
notre problème c'était l'avant qu'ovide
c'est qu'on avait trop de dette publique
dans l'économie française avant le coc
vide et puis notre question ça va être
la praye coville justement va en parler
en termes de politique économique est ce
qu'on a fait quelque part une espèce de
saut dans l'inconnu parce que voir le
déficit public français financés par ce
qu'on appelle de la création monétaire
dans de telles proportions pardon mais
avant la crise c'était inimaginable
impensable alors d'aller aussi loin
david jacquot de la chaux-de-fonds être
précis et je suis obligé de réagir à ce
que vous dites ce déficit financé par la
création monétaire il ya eu deux
interventions publiques massives ya eu
l'intervention budgétaire il le fallait
pour les raisons qu'on m'a dit ah de
soutien aux entreprises et à travers les
entreprises aux salariés aux français et
puis il ya eu une politique monétaire
très active pour contrer le risque de
déflation si nous avons agi c'est pas
pour financer les états c'est parce que
souvenez vous début 2020 on avait une
inflation qui était déjà trop faible et
on était menacée par cette grave maladie
de l'économique et la déflation et vous
avez n'avons pas yaya pas on pose la
question de la planche à billets il n'y
a pas de planche à billets d'ailleurs
c'est interdit par le traité de
maastricht et les statuts de la bce
quand nous achetons de la dette publique
nous l'achetons toujours oui pardon de
cette pression sur le manque toujours
sur le marché secondaire donc il a fallu
avant nous et qu'il y ait des
investisseurs privés français ou
internationaux qui a préfacé in fine
c'est bien dans les comptes de la bce
sur l'aide aux cayes à hier chez le
cadre est ya une partie sur le marché de
l'occasion pour hu dit qui va
temporairement dans le bilan de monsieur
mais cette partie est elle même limité
c'est une minorité de la dette au plus
haut de la crise d'ailleurs
j'ai lu que plus de la moitié de la
dette publique des états européens ont
été achetés par la bce on est mars avril
mai 2020 je crois qu'il faut on va
regarder la dette française par exemple
quand vous regardez l'ensemble de la
dette publique française au sens il y en
a entre 20 et 25% qui est détenu petite
partie par la bce la plus grosse partie
par la banque de france il faut
reconnaître que sans l'intervention
encore une fois et l'action des banques
centrales notamment ce plan d'urgence
pandémique 1850 milliards d'euros la
crise sanitaire ce serait doublée d'un
ko
devenir absolument est dans une crise
économique beaucoup plus grave non je
crois que quand je parlais tout à
l'heure de rapidité d'action c'est ça
qui a été réussie de ce point de vue là
d'ailleurs on a appris des crises
précédentes y compris la crise de 2008
c'est qu'il y avait une crise sanitaire
qui avait la priorité
rappelez-vous le choix qui a été fait
c'est un beau choix de solidarité je
trouve humainement qui est de dire on
prend le risque de quasiment arrêté
l'économie pour sauver des vies et ça a
marché c'est ça le confinement donc il y
avait une crise économique il fallait
éviter que s'ajoute à ça une crise
sociale et une crise financière avec une
perte générale de confiance saissac a
permis l'intervention des actionnaires
voilà c'est dit après c'est quoi qu'il
en coûte il a fonctionné d'un point de
vue économique on a retrouvé notre
niveau de prospérité d'avant crise et au
milieu de l'année 2021 alors la france
là à retrouver loyer le niveau scénario
ville un peu plus tôt que prévu et un
peu plus tôt que ses voisins européens
nous avons eu un fort rebond en août
dernier en août septembre dernier voilà
mais la contrepartie encore une fois dû
quoi qu'il en coûte c'est l'envolée de
cette dette publique française 15 points
de pib en deux ans il ya une question
qui revient souvent parce qu'on est en
campagne présidentielle certains disent
il faut pas la rembourser cette dette
kovy d'otis besse i fall à rembourser
votre position j'imagine autres de
fournir à la rembourser une dette ça ne
peut pas être annulé
d'abord y est une question de confiance
fissiles à des traders servent encore
quelques fois en 10 mais c'est différent
pour la banque centrale elle elle
pourrait annuler nous n'avons absolument
pas le droit de le faire ça ce serait
vraiment nu financement monétaire des
déficits donc c'est incompatible avec le
traité de l'euro
supposons même qui est une possibilité
juridique
ça ne rapporte absolument rien aux
français pour une raison très simple que
je veux vous rappeler c'est que la dette
française détenue par la banque de
france et à peu près 700 milliards
d'euros si on l'a nul d'un trait pendant
une seconde nous sommes collectivement
enrichi de 700 milliards mais ça veut
dire qu'on constate un trou de 700
milliards dans les comptes de la banque
de france et la banque de france elle
appartient à tous les français avouent à
l'ensemble des joueurs est donc
immédiatement on constate une perte de
700 milliards équivalent dans le
patrimoine des français on n'a rien
gagné par contre on a entamé fortement
la confiance dans la monnaie qui est
notre premier trésor et dont nous sommes
les garants donc à vous écouter il faut
vraiment s'inquiéter devant cette
envolée de cette dette publique
française sur deux ans et 450 milliards
d'euros donc certes on se dit que c'est
beaucoup mais quand on regarde par dont
la charge d'intérêts ce serait le
service de la thèse que ça coûte tous
les ans au budget de l'état on est au
plus bas depuis les années 80 est-ce
qu'on n'est pas en train de dramatiser
là alors il s'agit pas de dramatiser il
se juge de regarder les faits est
d'abord je rappelle les chiffres avant
comme vide nous étions déjà 100 % de
dette publique après le vide nous sommes
à 115% et quand on regarde si on
prolonge simplement les tendances vers
le rythme de croissance le rythme de
hausse des dépenses publiques nous avons
eu depuis dix ans on n'arrivera pas à
faire reculer ce sont 15 % les accès les
japonais en 200 points de 100% de ratio
dette / thézan sont pas morts les
japonais sont un cas extrêmement
particulier avec peu de croissance avec
une démographie qui recule c'est pas du
tout transposable à la france et à
l'europe et donc quand on si on prolonge
simplement et qu'on reste à 115% je dis
clairement aujourd'hui que ça n'est pas
soutenable ça n'est pas soutenable
d'abord parce que les taux d'intérêt
risquent de remonter on va parler tout à
l'heure de l'inflation et puis on avait
des taux d'intérêt exceptionnellement
bas jusqu'à présent je vais vous citer
un chiffre
david jacquot si les taux d'intérêt
remontent de 1% dans les années qui
viennent ces quartiers d'une ardeur ce
qui n'est pas un scénario extrême en dix
ans et près de 40 milliards d'euros à
terme
sur dix 40 milliards d'euros ça peut
paraître abstrait c'est l'ensemble du
budget de la défense nationale
aujourd'hui il ya un effet boule de
neige un effet boule de neige et il ya
eu un effet très favorable de ces taux
très bas mais il serait irresponsable de
parier l'avenir de la france sur le
maintien de cet honneur et puis il ya
d'autres risques il peut y avoir une
autre crise malheureusement nous vivons
dans un monde très incertain il faut à y
avoir moyen d'y faire face et puis nous
aurons des besoins d'investissements
très important sur le changement
climatique maintenant c'est souhaitable
donc on ne peut pas se permettre de
laisser la dette à ce niveau de 115%
parce qu'aujourd'hui se financent à taux
zéro mais ça sera pas le cas dit amateur
mais c'est pour ça que je me disais que
si ça remonte de 1% et on voit que c'est
un scénario il y à des scénarios plus
fort ça serait très coûteux donc je
crois que l'objectif qu'il faut que nous
donnions dans la durée on va pas faire
ça en un an ou deux mais en disant c'est
de dire il faut d'ici dix ans ramener la
dette publique nettement sous les 100%
du pile et ça c'est possible on va sans
doute y venir avec un peu plus de
croissance et moins de hausse des
dépenses un petit mode et des actifs
financiers parce qu'on a cac 40 qui a
pris quand même 30 % l'an dernier les
prix de l'immobilier sont en forte
hausse 7% sur un an est ce que c'est
parce que certains experts disent tout
ça c'est un petit peu aussi la faute
entre guillemets de la banque centrale
européenne qu'elle est pour partie
responsables de cette envolée des actifs
financiers au travers de sa politique
monétaire qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez pas ce que ça creuse aussi les
inégalités de patrimoine de beaucoup de
français alors là aussi il faut être
précis sur cette question il ya les
actifs financiers la bourse etc ça ça
évolue essentiellement en fonction de
l'économie comme aux états unis et en
europe donc comme il ya eu un bon rebond
économique il ya eu un rebond des
bourses sur les actifs immobiliers je
crois qui est d'abord cela profite à une
part beaucoup plus importante de la
population il ya beaucoup de français
qui sont propriétaires de leur logement
et là les taux d'intérêt peuvent jouer
un rôle mais il ya bien d'autres raisons
il ya une aspiration de plus en plus
des familles à avoir leur logement il ya
les phénomènes démographiques compris
les familles recomposées donc on estime
que le besoin de logements en france
comme dans tous les pays avancés
augmente régulièrement qu'en face de sa
l'offre ne suis pas tout à fait donc ça
c'est des raisons qui n'appartiennent
pas c'est parfois de la bce c'est
déprimant billets sont si un point de
vigilance qui est très important c'est
de vérifier que dans ce développement
fort du crédit immobilier il n'y ait pas
de risque de surendettement des ménages
et c'est pour ça que nous avons pris
avec le haut conseil de stabilité
financière que j'anime et que bruno
lemaire président nous avons pris des
mesures assez forts pour dire pas de
crédit au delà de 25 ans et pas de
charge de remboursement au delà 35% des
revenus vous vous souvenez peut-être que
ça a été assez critique et je note
qu'aujourd'hui ça se passe bien c'est
accepté par tout le monde et nous avons
concilier le bon financement de
l'immobilier avec l'absence de risque de
surendettement des français est-ce
qu'elle risque d'une crise boursière
d'une crise financière est plus élevé
aujourd'hui
par rapport au corps une fois la
situation pré crise parce que le monde
entier aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup plus
de dettes partout chez tous les agents
économiques ménages entreprises est un
donc la stabilité financière elle est
plus forte aujourd'hui rappelez-vous ce
qu'on craignait en mars 2020 c'est une
crise financière qui s'ajoute à la crise
y habiter à la crise économique on
craignait au chic que des banques des
compagnies d'assurances soit très
fragilisée nous n'avons pas eu cela et
ça je crois que c'est une bonne nouvelle
permise en partie par l'action des
autorités monétaires puis les
superviseurs que nous sommes est un
système bancaire et d'assurance solide
maintenant il ya un certain nombre de
risques probablement qui ont été
reportés sur le moyen terme il y à
l'accumulation de la dette publique nous
en avons parlé puis il ya certaines
valorisations de certains marchés
boursiers qui peuvent paraître élevés
nous suivons ça très précisément la
banque de france vient de publier début
janvier ce qu'elle appelle son
évaluation des risques systémiques
risque très élevé de 13 nous avons dit
précisément que vous pouvez regarder
cette étude est remarquablement fait
donc vous me permettez diddy renvoyer
c'est qu'il ya moins de risques à court
terme que ce qu'on pouvait craindre ya
un an ou deux mais qu'à moyen terme il
faut surveiller notamment la
valorisation des marchés boursiers voilà
et comment les que fait d'ailleurs pour
le coup la bce pour éviter
un potentiel une potentielle explosion
encore une fois une correction sur les
marchés boursiers où sur l'immobilier
quelques faits alors la bce pour info
être très clair sur les objectifs de la
bce la banque de france qui fait partie
de cet euro système notre premier
objectif c'est la stabilité des prix
donc c'est ça la boussole de notre
action les prix incluant les actifs non
repris ceux des prix à la consommation l
équilibre entre l'offre et la demande
dans l'économie et chasser la définition
qu'on retienne toutes les banques sont
tenues vous regardez aussi les actifs
financent alors nous regardons si un
certain nombre d'effets secondaires par
rapport à la politique monétaire visant
la stabilité des prix nous surveillons
les risques financiers mais il ya une
boussole central je crois que c'est ça
qui fait la force d'ailleurs de
l'eurosystème et des banques centrales
c'est que nous avons une mission un
mandat et c'est ça qui inspire la
confiance dans la monnaie des
européennes l'inflation et s'éteint l'un
des héritages de cette crise est
inflation qui revient plus fortement que
ce qui était attendu près de 5% en euros
3 % pour le coup en france est ce que
vous n'avez pas un petit peu sous-estimé
cette poussée d'inflation qui pour vous
pour vous êtes une bosse en sept sorties
crois qu'il faut revenir sur ce qui
s'est passé sur cette botte on l'a
peut-être oublié il ya un an l'inflation
en france est en hausse de 0,1 et ce
pont-là souvenez-vous tout le monde
s'inquiétait d'une inflation trop basse
je n'ai pas souvenir qui est énormément
de voix à l'époque qui ai dit attention
l'inflation arrive les cours du pétrole
même d'ailleurs étaient en territoire il
ya même eu des guerres du pétrole
négatif au printemps 2009 tout ça était
une autre aberration d'ailleurs alors
depuis qu'est ce qu'on voit c'est qu'à
proportion de la force de la reprise
économique
il ya des tensions sur les prix de
l'énergie et puis des difficultés
d'approvisionnement sur certaines
matières premières ou les semi
conducteurs donc c'est ça qui donne la
bosse d'inflation
cette bosse a été un peu plus haute est
un peu plus longue que ce qu'on
anticipait encore au printemps dernier
mais encore une fois c'est l
anticipation de tout le monde ce que
nous voyons aujourd'hui comme la plupart
des prévisions c'est que l'inflation
devrait décroître progressivement au
long de cette année parce qu'on va quand
même vers une forme de stabilisation des
cours de l'énergie et puis que les
difficultés d'approvisionnement
devraient diminuer et donc dans notre
prévision centrale l'inflation en france
descendrait redescendrait sous 2% d'ici
la fin de cette année mais je veux
insister sur deux choses parce que cette
question est très importante
la première c'est qu'on revient après
vers quelque chose qui n'est pas le
régime preco vide d'inflation trop
faible ou quasi zéro dont je parlais on
revient sans doute vers un nouveau
régime d'inflation plus proche de notre
cible de 2% et la deuxième chose sur
laquelle je voudrais insister c'est que
là je viens de vous dire une prévision
de qualité la meilleure que nous
puissions faire aujourd'hui c'est pas
une certitude aveugle nous avons à tout
moment les yeux grands ouverts sur les
données économiques réels et le dialogue
avec les entrepreneurs et les acteurs
économiques et si l'inflation devait
devenir plus persistantes n'ayez aucun
doute sur notre capacité à réduire
volontairement pour ramener l'inflation
durablement autour de notre objectif de
2% ça c'est une garantie très importante
que je donne aux français que nous
donnons collectivement aux acteurs
opèrent alors il ya un phénomène majeur
qui est un petit peu un des enfants de
cette crise et l'accélération de la
transition énergétique est ce que cette
accélération de la part notamment des
états notamment de la france vous l'a
saluée mais ça vous a surpris parce que
c'est paris pas de lien direct entre la
pandémie long je crois que c'est une
bonne chose il aimait le gel des
craintes qu'on pouvait avoir
initialement et que le coc vide éclipse
le climat je crois qu'au contraire
l'urgence de la transition climatique
est aujourd'hui partagée de plus en plus
est au fond quand je regarde l'ensemble
de l'europe et que je me projette à
presles que vite sur les dix ans qui
viennent nous allons devoir réussir deux
grandes transitions la transition
climatique
vers une économie décarbonée
et la transition numérique avec
davantage de digital ça c'est les deux
grands chantiers de l'ensemble des
européens il ya des chantiers plus
spécifique à la france dont nous parlons
après le problème de l'offre de travail
et le problème
de chantier et serait la bce ont fait
suffisamment pour lutter justement
contre le réchauffement climatique au
delà de cette prise de conscience qu'on
a bien vu ce risque est là le jab
essieux et la banque de france ya pris
une grande consommation y compris d'un
sur une proposition d'un helvète la bce
est absolument pionnière à l'échelle
mondiale dans le verdissement de sa
politique monétaire concrètement très
concrètement nous avons décidé en
juillet dernier autour de christine
lagarde lorsqu'on a appelé à l'époque la
revue stratégique de politique monétaire
un programme de verdissement que nous
allons appliquer d'ici 2024 d'ici deux
ans en intégrant le climat dans toutes
nos prévisions économiques c'est un
sacré travail et en intégrant le risque
climatique dans les actifs d'entreprise
que nous achetons ou que nous prenons en
garantie pour des refinancements
technique
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire été
conçu quand on prend des effectifs on en
est venu évidemment la valeur financière
mais nous allons aussi en évaluer le
risque climatique ça aussi c'est un gros
travail de méthode mais nous sommes la
première banque centrale au monde dans
les grandes banques centrales à l'avoir
décidée et elle met en eux nous sommes
en campagne présidentielle et après le
quoi qu'il en coûte
les français pourraient croire que les
poches de l'état sont très profondes ou
infini en parlait justement des grands
thèmes économiques de cette campagne a
tort si les français croyaient que des
poches de l'état sont infinies je crois
qu'il faut revenir sur ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure sur la ce qu'on a comme
liv est quasiment 200 milliards d'euros
pour financer encore dû aller tous les
plans d'urgence il y avait 200 milliards
200 millions david jacquot y fait des
circonstances ont absolument
exceptionnel que cette crise qu vide on
n'avait rien vu de tel depuis 1945 donc
il fallait évidemment des réponses
exceptionnelles mais une fois sortis de
la crise restait sur le niveau actuel de
dette publique ne serait pas soutenable
pour les raisons que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure le risque de remontée des taux
les besoins que nous allons avoir
donc il faut se donner les moyens sur
les dix ans qui viennent de baisser la
dette et c'est possible
pour revenir sous les 100% je crois
d'abord qu'il faut davantage de
croissance on va sans doute en parler
une des vraies difficultés de la france
c'est que notre cross qu'on appelait les
économistes appellent la croissance
potentielle c'est à dire notre
croissance tendancielle en gros a été
divisé par deux depuis 20 ou 30 ans on
est passé de autour de 2% par an à un
peu plus de 1 pour ceux d'autres pays
européens aussi s'est passé c'est un
problème général de l'europe il se
trouve simplement qu'il ya des pays
européens qui ont mieux réussi
l'allemagne un certain nombre de pays
d'europe du nord donc il faut qu'on
regarde mais c'est pas du tout des
remèdes idéologique des solutions très
pratique ce que nous pouvons faire en
france qui a marché dans d'autres pays
européens ayant le même modèle social
que nous et puis alors il ya une
dernière composante qui est très
importante c'est une meilleure maîtrise
et une meilleure efficacité de nos
dépenses publiques
c'est vraiment dans le débat s'est pas
vraiment dans le tempo oui mais voilà
cette manière c'est important de lits m
jeudi au passage dans le débat il ya
plutôt des propositions dans l'autre
sens il ya beaucoup d'idées de dépenses
supplémentaires de baisses d'impôts
additional aliments il faut le dire très
clairement la france n'a pas les moyens
aujourd'hui de dégrader davantage ses
dépenses publiques parce que qu'est ce
que nous faisons quand nous consentons
des baisses d'impôts supplémentaires ou
des dépenses non financées nous
transmettons la facture à nos enfants à
nos petits enfants eux ils vont devoir
rembourser la facture avec des taux
d'intérêt qui risque d'être beaucoup
moins favorables qu'aujourd'hui après
cette priorité aujourd'hui des français
la priorité des français dans cette
campagne électorale c'est le pouvoir
d'achat ça quand on pose la question
c'est assez clair est ce que pour vous
c'est l'est vraiment la mer des
priorités alors là je crois qu'on arrive
sur l'autre grand défi français on
vienne pas et de la dette publique
l'autre grand défi français si cette
question de croissance potentielle quand
vous regardez les projections de la
banque de france la croissance est forte
en 2021 2020 de encore assez bonne en
2023 puisque l effet de rattrapage
qu'ovide mais en 2024 nous descendrions
1,4 pour cent et on retrouverait petit à
petit stand ans autour de 1,1 pour cent
ça ça n'est pas assez et ça touche
directement la question du pouvoir
d'achat
pourquoi parce que depuis des années
nous n'avons pas assez de croissance et
ça ça veut dire quand on veut soutenir
le pouvoir d'achat
on le fait au prix d'une dérive de la
dépense publique et de la dette publique
et c'est un peu artificielle par comment
est ce qu'on fait dans sa partie ciel
pour durablement créer du pouvoir
d'achat sainement pour aussi david
jacquot abaisser le taux de chômage qui
reste plus élevé chez nous à queue en
allemagne comme très bien aujourd'hui en
france alors il a baissé mais beaucoup
de nos voisins on ne sait pas toujours
sont à 5 % de taux de chômage
c'est-à-dire quasiment le plein emploi
nous on est encore entre 7 et 8 on a
encore deux millions quatre cent mille
chômeurs 600000 jeune sané ça n'est pas
acceptable socialement on peut pas se
résigner à ça donc je crois que le sujet
qui est derrière touche à cette
insuffisance de croissance il pose des
problèmes du pouvoir d'achat de la dette
du 16 05 pour sa croissance qui sont en
croissance alors ce que nous disons
c'est qu'il serait souhaitable de gagner
en gros un demi point de croissance tant
cesse le passé de un peu plus de 1 à
quelque chose qui est entre 1,5 et 2 et
que c'est possible alors les
transformations européenne dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure le numérique le
climatiques peuvent apporter en gros un
tiers de ce chemin mais les deux tiers
relève de nous et après tout c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle nous avons
notre destin en main et le principal
sujet français sur insuffisance de
croissance c'est pas l'insuffisance de
dépenses publiques nous en avons
beaucoup c'est même pas l'insuffisance
d'investissements de capital
d'investissement est plutôt plus élevé
en france que chez nos voisins
investissements des entreprises comme
investissement plaque en fait c'est la
quantité d'offres de travail disponible
pour les employeurs publics comme privés
d'ailleurs et là la comparaison avec
l'allemagne est malheureusement très
éclairante quand on regarde le taux
d'emploi c'est-à-dire la part de la
population qui a un emploi
il a monté un peu en france qui est une
bonne nouvelle mais malheureusement nous
avons un écart très important que
l'allemagne c'est 75 % en allemagne 67 %
en france mais ça c'est avec les gens
que vous savez combien ça fait d'emploi
si je rapporte ça la population
française ça fait 3 millions d'emplois
qui nous manque merci françois villeroy
de galhau le gouverneur de la banque de
france donc merci pour cet entretien
exclusif évidemment entretien à voir ou
revoir sur public sénat et en replay
évidemment sur publicsenat.fr rendez
vous dans deux semaines
[Musique]